Prime Minister Boris Johnson has tested
positive for the Cova Denine teen
coronavirus he says however he will be
continuing to lead the UK's outbreak
response straight to London his Lawrence
Lee Lawrence how did the announcement
come out on Twitter Kemal by some
distance the most important world
leaders who have announced he's
contracted the virus
the corona virus frankly has the the
epicenter of it in London which is the
epicenter of the country the epicenter
in London has actually been around
Westminster as several MPs lots of
political journalists people who work in
Whitehall have all said that they'd got
is Boris Johnson obviously is in is is
in regular contact with all of these
people every day and so obviously on one
level if you look at it you think where
the Prime Minister's got coronavirus
that's amazing
but also it's not really that unex it's
quite unexpectedly expect it's in a
sense it's not really much of a surprise
anyway he said he managed to get through
a two minute long video on Twitter
without coughing once which is pretty
amazing given that an uncontrollable
cough is one of the symptoms and he said
the symptoms were quite Marling's going
to try and carry on you can judge for
yourselves here's a clip of the video
I've developed mild symptoms of the
corona virus that's to say a temperature
and a persistent cough and on the advice
of the chief medical officer I've taken
a test that has come out positive so I
am working from the home I'm so Faisal
ating and that's entirely the right
thing to do but being no doubt that I
can continue a thanks to the wizardry of
modern technology to communicate with
all my top team to lead the national
fight back against coronavirus so
Lawrence does that suggest them that
Boris Johnson is still in charge because
I would think usually when the Prime
Minister is incapacitated in any way
shape or form he or she would be well
there's no technically Deputy Prime
Minister in the UK is there how would it
work no it would be they'd probably be
the
the Foreign Secretary Dominic Raab but I
don't think it's it doesn't look that
serious unless it gets a lot worse very
quickly and he said you know gumming
governments are doing business by
videoconference nowadays anyway and so I
suspect it's probably not going to be
any any different that they're the
health secretary Matt Hancock he's gonna
have to self isolate too because he's be
the only cabinet minister holding any
sort of daily discussions with Boris
Johnson so again it would be
unsurprising if he announced he got it
as well at some point in the next few
days the more interesting thing Kemal
just briefly it's actually been the
public response because the only a
couple of days ago prince charles
announce that he'd got it a lot of
people rather than expressing concern
for ever for Prince Charles said well
how come he got tested for the virus
when when doctors and nurses and the
public aren't getting tested a lot of
people if you look at them if you look
at the Twitter are now making exactly
the same points about Boris Johnson how
come he got a test and other people
didn't thank you for all that update
from Lawrence Lee there on the news that
Boris Johnson the British prime minister
has tested positive for corona virus